foreign
[Music]
you're an interesting man
Scotland
um I don't know who you are but
you've made a big mistake
okay
I'm an Avenger
I've called the other Avengers you're an
Avenger
have I killed you before
what
they all blow together after a while
you're not the one with the hammer
that's Thor
we get confused a lot similar body types
who are you
just a man
who's lost a lot of time
like you
but we can help each other with that
there are beings down here intelligent
beings I always theorized it was
possible but to be here
a subatomic Universe this changes
everything we know about life Evolution
our place in the galaxy
like that looks like broccoli
so you've been studying the quantum
Realm
[Music]
why didn't you ask me about it I tried
Mom
a lot you never wanted to talk about it
Cassie's just been curious and we gave
her some pointers this isn't exactly ant
science is it Henry
you know how dangerous the quantum realm
is we all do Mom nobody's going to the
quantum realm that's why we made this
it's like a satellite for deep space or
the ocean
but
Quanah
we just need a map
and then we can study and explore the
entire Quantum Realm
never even have to go
your daughter built a subatomic Hubble
telescope in a basement
[Music]
gone and
I could have found him
you know I promised your mom that you
would only use this stuff when one of us
was around it's really dangerous Tech I
know it's dangerous what if the cops
took it from you what if you lost it I
didn't lose the suit you have a suit
wait you have a suit I know how to take
care of myself okay trust me I'm pretty
good at it by now
ouch
I didn't mean it like that I'm sorry
that's okay it's all right I get it
I just think you should get to have a
normal life
that a guy dressed like a bee tried to
kill me in my room when I was six
how about some music
in that moment I think was how did the
Hulk turn me into a baby will I be a
baby forever am I the Hulk's baby dad
are you listening to your own book but I
was ready for it no that's uh Stephen
this is the radius over there it's so
weird something's wrong with this switch
it won't turn off I said turn it off
what's that turn it up all right a
little after that a raccoon from space
showed up I don't think he knew my name
I was just happy to meet a raccoon who
could talk
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
we could help each other with that
how are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
they can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
he can give us a second chance
foreign
[Music]
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
foreign
[Music]
you come from above
like him
he will burn the world to find you
oh
the Conqueror
Kang the Conqueror is the new iconic
villain in the MCU
we knew we wanted to go to places that
we'd never been
kind of pity Ant-Man against a major
villain felt perfect
audiences have seen a version of this
character in the series Loki
this is wild
in our film he's very different hang is
an infinite number of different personas
and you need an actor to be able to pull
that off and that is Jonathan majors
I can rewrite existence and shatter
timelines in this film this is really a
side of him we haven't seen this is his
baddest self I will take my revenge on
those who banished me and I will burn
them out of time
I think the film is awesome about how
time plays within our relationship love
friendship Legacy Ant-Man versus tank
this is it people gonna lose their mind
you heard of your league at man
[Music]
I just think you should get to have a
normal life dad a guy dressed like a bee
tried to kill me in my room when I was
six daddy is that you hey peanut
Cassie Lang wants to change the world
I have a suit yeah I noticed she likes
the chaos she wants to be fighting and
she wants to be in the middle of it
she's being influenced by these
superheroes around her
you know if I had something like this
when you were gone
I could have found you
[Music]
Catherine take on Cassie she just shows
up and she's just got it
[Music]
the boy at energy of her character was
so great she just wants to be a
superhero like her dad she wants to
impress him momentum right jump attack I
know how to do it dad oh do you
we always love doing the unexpected with
Scott black Batman is arguably the
character that is the most
underestimated Ant-Man became the key to
saving the universe in Avengers end game
so carrying that tradition we thought
well let's use this film to kick off
phase five
been almost a decade now that I've been
playing this part I've loved it and I
feel protective of Scott Lang and
Ant-Man it's really nice coming back I
still kind of can't believe that I'm
sitting there and it's like wow there's
Michelle Pfeiffer and there's Michael
Douglas I just saved eight bucks admire
you it's really nice not to get used to
working with Legends
[Music]
down to the quantum Realm
where are we it's a secret Universe
beneath ours Janet has been very quiet
about her time in the quantum realm
maybe would have made different choices
there's someone I never told you man
just this isn't what you think Kang the
Conqueror is terrifying and if there
ever was a maniac loose in the quantum
realm it's him
playing Kang the Conqueror is such a
gift your reality
everything you're holding on to I know
how it is this is the beginning and he
cannot be contained
something like this which is so
transportive and visually striking
people should really see it in a movie
theater you want it to be as big and as
visceral and assuming as possible
audiences are going to watch this and go
I can't believe this is happening it's
going to be bonkers
it's like we're camping we've never been
camping but we've always talked about it
[Music]
foreign